this protest has been on again off again
for two weeks but when it's on it's big
at times in recent days the line of
trucks is stretched from the border back
20 kilometers the weight to get through
more than 30 hours
this organizer is a ukrainian refugee
she says the goal is to isolate russia
and bring ukraine closer to victory
the fear is russia may be evading some
of the pain from sanctions by still
getting deliveries from western europe
goods and food could be moved to russia
through belarus a country that's been an
ally in its invasion of ukraine
this activist says he has friends in
belarus they've suffered under their
leader as well and he says they support
the blockade
some trucks have been allowed through if
the cargo is hazardous or livestock but
just about everything else is being
slowed down including empty trucks that
may be heading back after making
deliveries from belarus or russia
there have been face-offs with
frustrated truckers at times
strucker says he feels sorry for the
protesters that they're wasting their
time and won't change anything
they are getting some support from
polish politicians the prime minister
over the weekend said he'll be proposing
to the european union that it add to the
current sanctions a full trade blockade
of russia both by land and sea
mike armstrong global news jeshof poland
[Music]